[Music]
on this friday night a prescription to
fix canada's ailing health care system
the five-point plan from some ontario
unions if premier ford doesn't like our
plan then
what's his plus how medical workers are
calling it quits
mounting monkey pox angst the vaccine
supply concerns and calls for a federal
strategy to stop the spread retaliation
ramping up beijing's latest response to
the u.s house speaker's trip to taiwan
and a menu that's really the cat's meow
in my time working here i have learned
to never underestimate how crazy some
cat crazy people are the restaurant
cooking up fancy feline inspired food
for humans
global national with bara nasser
[Music]
good evening thank you for joining us
the latest job numbers for canada and
the u.s telling two very different
stories about the state of our economy
south of the border job losses had been
forecast but new data out today shows
more americans are working than ever
before defying fears about a post-covet
recession now here despite forecasts for
moderate job growth canada's economy
shed jobs for the second month in a row
new data from statistics canada shows 31
000 jobs were lost in july once again
the health care sector saw a decline
with a loss of 22 000 workers and
coveted burnout is playing a role last
month over 11 percent of nurses across
the country called in sick at least once
and more than 21 percent had to work
paid overtime
also according to statscan there are
more than 140 000 job vacancies in
healthcare right across the country
tens of thousands of those job openings
are in canada's largest province but as
ross lord explains in our top story
tonight those on the front lines of
health care in ontario and those in
charge are increasingly at odds on how
to fix the health care staffing crisis
every day there are more voices in
canadian health care crying for help
among those growing increasingly
desperate are emergency room doctors the
situations that i see where my patient
with a dislocated shoulder
is screaming for hours
and i can't find a better nurse to put
that back in senior nurses leaving the
profession leaving the profession or
leaving emergency medicine nursing which
is a huge problem nurses are burned out
or staving off exhaustion begging for
the public to understand that the
workload is unsafe it is unsustainable
and we need to do something to encourage
nurses to stay in the profession in
ontario three healthcare unions are
pleading with the government of premier
doug ford to listen or at least work
with them to make improvements the
union's five point plan includes
supporting the existing health care
workforce repealing bill 124 which
restricts wage increases financial
incentives to keep staff from leaving
incentives for nurses and others who are
licensed but not working
and significantly expanding
post-secondary spaces for health
disciplines including waiving tuition
fees if premier ford doesn't like our
plan then
what's his
premier ford likes to say that ontario
is open for business but how long will
that be true when our health care system
is closed there are premiers out there
that are looking to make improvements to
health care this week newfoundland and
labrador announced eight measures
designed to recruit and keep nurses
including retention and signing bonuses
child care and mental health supports
we're here to announce hope
for the registered nurses the nurse
practitioners and the healthcare workers
and our patients we started this a
couple of months ago with the nurse's
think tank
and then immediately action the items
that came out of it the kind of
collaboration sadly lacking in ontario
where a new government promised to fast
fast-track doctors trained outside of
canada is being met with skepticism by
doctors and nurses and the premier's
reassurances that 90 percent of
emergency room patients receive proper
care are being denounced as misleading
only 24
of patients
requiring admission to hospital
meet the provincial benchmark a long way
to go it seems before canada's largest
province makes a concerted push to fix
health care
ross lord global news
all this while monkey pox cases are
climbing in canada and the window to
stamp out the virus is rapidly closing
nearly two weeks after the world health
organization declared it a public health
emergency and a day after the u.s
followed suit health experts are now
urging canadian officials to take action
jamie morocco reports and a warning some
of the images in this story are graphic
wesley wallace hopes it's his last day
in quarantine tomorrow is doctor haircut
and gym after nearly a month inside
suffering from monkey pox i'm hoping my
my face will look back to normal
hopefully in a couple of weeks see
across north america cases of the
disease have been on the rise surpassing
7 thousand in the u.s the most of any
country in the world we are going to do
everything that we can
to end this outbreak thursday the biden
administration declared the outbreak an
emergency unlocking money and resources
to acquire and administer more vaccines
as some americans scrambled to get a
shot canada hasn't faced the same
problems with supply and demand but as
cases here approach 1000 there are
concerns about the possible impact of a
global supply shortage theoretically we
should be able to eradicate monkey pox
if we had enough vaccine and so
vaccination is really critical
for getting this virus under control the
public health agency of canada says it's
deploying over 80 000 doses to provinces
and territories but it would not comment
on declaring a national emergency even
after the world health organization has
if canada doesn't want to declare a
public health emergency after the
international organization on health
does then i think it would be important
to explain why quebec succeeded in
tamping down case counts without federal
involvement in ontario however cases are
surging the province's health ministry
didn't respond to our request on whether
it's considering any emergency measures
if we have sort of a
hodgepodge approach to this so some
cities or provinces do it one way and
others do it a different way we're going
to
we're going to lose our opportunity to
control it leaving federal authorities
little time to decide if and when they
will step in
jamie morrocker global news toronto
the federal government is moving to ban
handgun imports in this country in the
latest effort to get firearms off our
streets
we can't tolerate the status quo
as i said we've seen
additional loss of innocent life in
montreal three more people lost to gun
violence the last few days we continue
to see shootings here in my hometown
in toronto and right across the country
the status quo is unacceptable
the ban will go into effect in two weeks
and is going to stay in place until
parliament votes on bill c-21
that is designed to strengthen canada's
gun laws the public safety minister says
that vote will take place hopefully this
fall
our auto bureau chief mercedes stevenson
joins us now so mercedes what exactly is
this ban
so far what this will be is a ban on the
import of handguns to canada of course
that would be legal handguns and it's
being done by implementing a
stop on the import permit coming into
canada this is actually the foreign
affairs minister that will do it and
it's a stop gap measure until parliament
can pass that legislation it's something
that's politically important for the
liberals to do it's on brand for them
but it's a bit rare typically this kind
of thing would go through parliament but
in this particular case it will be going
through the import ban instead the vast
majority of legally imported handguns to
canada come from the united states so
this will hopefully address some of that
they're saying um but it is also
designed to address a flaw in their
previous announcement which was that
after they announced it there was a rush
on buying handguns because people knew
they were going to be banned they'll
still be two weeks to do this but it
will slow down some of that panic buying
and they're hoping will cap
the number of handguns being bought in
canada
okay so what does this mean though for
guns on the streets
well that's the big question is how many
of the handguns being used in crime on
the street are bought by legal owners
and stolen or used by legal owners
versus those that are being smuggled and
critics and a lot of experts have said
you know there is a huge problem with
smuggled handguns coming across into
canada especially in places like toronto
or vancouver this only addresses the
legal owners who are buying it and stops
them it does not stop the illegal
transfer of guns across the border and
experts say you know it's time to start
tracking where these guns come from so
we have a sense of just how many this
kind of a measure could stop and how
much more is needed
okay thank you so much for that mercedes
stevenson in ottawa
the fallout from u.s house speaker nancy
pelosi's visit to taiwan continues to
escalate with china now cutting off
high-level cooperation with the u.s in
several key areas including military
communications and crime prevention and
climate change talks
for the third straight day chinese
military jets scrambled over the taiwan
strait as the country's largest ever
live fire drills are set to continue
through the weekend
beijing also demonstrating its outrage
by summoning the american ambassador in
beijing and halting agricultural imports
from the island
china claims taiwan has its own
territory under the one china policy
while taiwan rejects those claims and is
vowing to defend itself
at least eight people were killed in a
series of israeli airstrikes in gaza
israel says the strike targeted and
killed a commander of the islamic jihad
group but gaza's health ministry says
seven other people including a
five-year-old girl also died when the
missiles hit the apartment building in
gaza city and three other sites at least
40 others were hurt these attacks follow
days of escalating tension following the
arrest of a senior palestinian leader by
israel and a closure of a key border
crossing into gaza
the top diplomats from both the u.s and
russia say negotiations are set to begin
for a prisoner exchange involving
basketball star brittany griner
on thursday groner was convicted on a
drug charge by a russian judge and
sentenced to nine years in prison
speaking at separate events the u.s
secretary of state anthony bilkin and
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
said negotiations would be conducted
through a special channel
we put forward as you know a substantial
proposal that russia has engaged with us
on
and
what foreign minister lavrov
said this morning and said publicly is
that they are prepared to engage through
channels we've established to do just
that and we'll be pursuing that
the biden administration has offered to
trade imprisoned russian arms dealer
victor bouch for griner and paul whelan
who is a former u.s marine was also
jailed in russia
three more ships carrying ukrainian
grain have left port under the u.n
brokered safe passage deal the ships are
carrying a total of nearly 60 000 tons
of corn and heading for ports in britain
ireland and turkey ukraine is a major
grain exporter but shipments were frozen
with the beginning of the war driving up
global food prices and prompting fears
of food shortages in africa and the
middle east ukraine's government is now
calling for the safe passage agreement
to be expanded to include more of its
exports such as metals
drought emergencies are being declared
in parts of western europe as the
continent is in the grips of the third
heat wave of the summer temperatures in
france hitting 40 degrees forcing the
implementation of water use restrictions
in an effort to preserve crops italy has
now recorded its driest year since
record keeping began in 1800
rainfall is down by 46 percent across
the country with the north of the
country being the worst affected
including the po river valley a major
food producing zone temperatures in
those areas topped 37 degrees today
the trial of a dutch man accused of
extorting a b.c teen amanda todd winds
down
coming up what the jury was told to keep
in mind when it deliberates
a decade after bc teenager amanda todd
took her own life following years of
online harassment the trial of her
alleged tormentor is coming to a close
dutch authorities arrested aiden cobin
in 2014 in an isolated cabin in the
netherlands he's accused of using nearly
two dozen online profiles to extort her
roominadea joins us now from the
courthouse where the jury has just begun
deliberating romina
farah there is no question 15 year old
amanda todd was the victim of crimes but
who was behind the online sextortion
identity is at the center of this case
crown is trying to prove 44 year old
dutch citizen aiden cobin was behind 22
phony user accounts used to sexually
blackmail the bc teen through facebook
half a world away
amanda killed herself in 2012. weeks
before the teen shared her story of
blackmail torment and depression in a
haunting youtube video viewed by
millions worldwide
i'm hopeful but i can't base my hope on
a hundred percent because if i don't
hear those words of guilty five times
i'll be really upset i'll be really
disappointed and i'll go down that
rabbit hole it's not only me that has
been advocating and making a voice
the story of amanda it's everyone that
has embraced her story a colossal amount
of evidence was seized from cobin's
holiday home in the netherlands
including several hard drives the name
amanda todd appearing multiple times
crown claims the hard drives contain
enough information to prove only one
person is responsible defense told the
jury there is no link between the online
extortionist and cobin arguing the
evidence shows other people were using
the facebook accounts plus some of the
devices showing communication with
amanda could have come into cobin's
possession because he was a computer
repairman
justice devlin warned the jury amanda's
death is not part of this trial cobin
has pleaded not guilty to all five
charges including possession of child
pornography extortion and criminal
harassment pharah
romina daya in new westminster bc thank
you romina
one day after a jury hit right-wing
conspiracy theorist and infowars host
alex jones with a 4 million defamation
judgment the jurors have decided that
he'll also have to pay punitive damages
as well in the amount of more than 45
million dollars the money is being
awarded to the parents of a six-year-old
boy killed in the sandy hook massacre
who sued jones for claiming the school
shooting was a hoax the jury heard
expert testimony and analysis about the
value of the web of media organizations
and shell companies controlled by jones
estimated at between 135 and 270 million
dollars
help wanted ahead what some employers
are doing when they can't find a human
to hire
despite a larger than expected number of
jobs lost the overall unemployment rate
across canada remains at a record low
4.9 percent now it's great news for
workers but it can make things more
challenging for businesses as ann
gaviola explains the pandemic has paved
the way for automation in a job market
where employers are struggling to find
workers
there are more than one million job
vacancies across canada right now and
good luck to employers trying to find
workers to fill them everybody's facing
the same challenge these days
part of it is obviously compensation but
part of it is also how do we treat our
employees labor experts say prolonged
staffing shortages and covid policies
are only adding to the case for
increasing automation in the workforce
after all robots don't call in sick
don't spread sickness and don't need
rest
like this robot barista in toronto's
kensington market neighborhood you might
mistake this for vending machine coffee
but it's made on demand from beans to
cup in under two minutes fully
contactless and open 24 7.
it's good i'm no match expert but it's
cold and it's refreshing what started
with one location in 2020 has now become
five i think this is
kind of
where we're going as a society i have
mixed feelings about a robot from a jobs
perspective the makers of these robot
barista cafes say they're job creators
not job killers there's the whole back
end system that we have in place that
has a whole lot of people running it
and developing it their cost savings
comes from low overhead and they plan to
expand across canada and the us we're
getting a tremendous
interest especially in the u.s
and also here with the universities in
canada where the labor market is so
tight that they just cannot get the
people in to actually get the jobs
filled with automation accelerating
because of the pandemic income
inequality concerns also increase with
lower income earners likely most at risk
we are embarking into a new type of
economy that we're not prepared to
regulate or manage and i don't think our
societies are ready for that but that is
the tidal wave of change that is coming
in this coming era he predicts that
tidal wave of change could unfold over
the next five to 10 years whether we're
ready for it is a whole other matter ann
gaviola global news toronto
up next the new italian trattoria aiming
to be the cat's meow in new york city
new york is always a foodie's delight
boasting some of the best restaurants in
the world well a fancy new pop-up is
offering quite the unique feast as
abigail beeman reports the italian style
tracheria was inspired by some of the
most finicky eaters
it doesn't really look like cat food and
to be clear it's not cat food but it may
remind you of your feline's favorite
dish welcome to gato bianco that means
white cat in italian a two night only
new york city pop-up restaurant meant to
help cat owners understand how their
cats experience food if i could love a
meal as much as an orange cat loves
eating at any time of the day
i think life would be better forever
doug ferguson is an official cat
whisperer at vancouver's cafe my time
working here i have learned to never
underestimate how crazy some cat crazy
people are
only 16 cat companions will get to per
take and it's free is it something you
would eat or something
probably both i personally probably
wouldn't go there but
it's interesting
there's an online recipe book should you
want to try things at home such as
de manzo or lemon panna cotta all
inspired by fancy feast wet cat food to
which taco bell responded hey wet meat
is our thing
whether you have feline fervor or our
contract kitties the marketing move is
the cat's pajamas representatives for
fancy feast describe the experience
saying the dishes at gato bianco are
prepared in ways that help cat owners
understand how their cats experience
food which is begrudgingly while waiting
for you to die so they can eat your
eyeballs
there is one hitch due to health and
safety guidelines you can't actually
bring your cat to gato bianco you're
better off at the cat cafe
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ah what's the point then that's it for
global national for friday night i'm
farah nasser on behalf of our whole team
here i want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is this nighttime
shot of canada place in downtown
vancouver we love seeing your canada so
please keep sending us your pictures to
viewers at globalnational.com
jeff semple will be on the anchor desk
over the weekend until monday take care
of yourselves and each other good night
[Music]
you